[Musique]
dans le documentaire de marie portolano
je ne suis pas une [ __ ] je suis une
journaliste a diffusé sur canal+ pierre
ménès avait fait l'objet de vives
critiques suite à son comportement
considéré comme misogyne et sexiste le
monde a changé qui s'est mis tout on
peut plus rien faire on peut plus rien
dire mais depuis les médias continuent
leurs recherches et publie régulièrement
de nouveaux témoignages à son encontre
comme celui de l'actrice alice belaïdi
qui déclarait il ya quelques semaines
sur europe 1 ce qui sort sur pierre
ménès sur moi aussi j'ai été victime de
sale [ __ ] [ __ ] de la part de de
ce mec là de son côté l'avocat de pierre
ménès plaide pour un retour du
journaliste dans le canal football club
émission monte il a été suspendu pour
lui les faits reprochés ne mérite pas
une telle résonance
une chose est sûre la sphère continue de
passionner les médias et porte préjudice
à la carrière de pierre menez qui s'est
vu aussi rompre son contrat avec les
spots pour ses commentaires dans le jeu
fifa
alors les médias ont-ils fait condamner
pierre ménès ce soir l'avocat de pierre
ménès arash derambarsh et avec no mercy
mettre des traversées c'est vrai que ça
fait longtemps qu'on attend que vous
avoir dans l'émission on va faire et
avoir un petit tour de table parce que
pour vous la question est la question
les simples aussi pour les
téléspectateurs et pour nous est ce que
les médias ont condamné pierre ménès
vous dites oui nicolas pernikoff bah oui
mais mais il s'est aussi mis une balle
dans le pied entre autres quand il est
venu sur le plateau c'est à dire que il
faut reconnaître parce que la défense
des deux carmenes n'a commis aucun acte
d'agression ni violent ni 1,16 mais si
acte d'agression si alors après moi ce
que je reproche c'est que ces sorties du
contexte et que tout le monde s'est
emballé et que tout le monde a repris
par l'andrh 48 heures ou 72 heures la
formation et l'a condamné à ce moment là
oui les médias qui ont fait condamner
pierre ménès d'abord tu l'as dit c'est
sa prise de parole qui a été désastreuse
et calamiteuse et qui a fait que ça
s'est retourné contre lui alors qu'il
venait ici pour essayer de se défendre
et expliquer ses pas et c'est bien
surtout quand il a coaché pris la parole
et par ailleurs les médias ne sont que
la caisse de résonance des réseaux
sociaux et de ce que le public a dit
c'est le public en premier les médias
ont suivi ensuite mais ils n'ont été que
la caisse de résonance c'est pas eux qui
ont initié la chose alors quelles sont
les nouvelles de pierre ménès d'avoir
merci pour votre invitation
pierre est fatigué
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire je vais
passer le bonjour alors à son épouse
également à mélissa vous savez que alors
je vous dis quand on demande comment on
va bien venus il ya plein de gens qui
disent c'est pas pire mais ce qu'il faut
demander comment il va qu'est ce que
vous répondez à sa sûr parce qu'il ya
des gens qui disent c'est pas bien passé
on a tout à fait d'abord est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qu'ils disent est en
très bonne question d'avoir je pense à
toutes ces femmes et au delà de
d'isabelle moreau de marie portolano de
francesca anthony je pense d'avoir
toutes les femmes victimes ou supposée
victime ou en tout cas qui dans le
silence souffre d' actes inappropriés
d'atteinte sexuelle d'agression sexuelle
ou de viol moi je ne suis pas venu ici
pour débattre sur le fond dans ce
dossier il ya une chose très importante
il est venu chez vous le 22 mai il ya un
mois pile le documentaire passé le 21
donc les venue le lendemain
si j'ai un conseil à donner en général
dans la vie c'est qu'il faut jamais
réagir à chaud il a pris le temps de
comprendre ce qui se passait l'ami une
semaine il a écouté il a analysé
est ce un être humain comme chacun de
nous moi je comprends que c'est que dans
notre époque on puisse avoir cette
cupidité cette avidité delà de la
virginité d'être propre je comprends on
a tous fauté tous moi vous chacun de
nous ici
il a fait un tweet ensuite après
réflexion il a présenté ses excuses
il a présenté ses excuses de façon
personnalisée et c'est un cheminement
qui lui a permis d'arriver à ça parce
que vous imaginez l'amour propre à notre
époque
connaissant permet ce je pense que vous
connaissez chacun il a mis son amour
propre et son ego de côté
il a présenté ses excuses et pour
arriver à ça il ya un chemin qui permet
d'y arriver c'est d'abord l'humilité
c'est la compréhension la compassion et
on aurait beaucoup à gagner dans notre
époque être je pense plus dans le fait
de tendre la main que
de tirer comme on fait aujourd'hui à
l'emporte-pièce bernard montiel puisque
vous êtes son avocat j'avoue que on en
est où est ce qu'il ya eu des plaintes
oui c'est vrai c'est important est ce
qui est des plaintes déposées c'est ça
on ne sait pas on sait que ces femmes là
elles ont bien fait la parole s'est
libérée l on dise que ce qu'elles ont
vécu leur humiliation et tout ça mais ce
qu'a eue et concrètement juridiquement
des plaintes des résidents qu'aux
applications sur mondiale merci beaucoup
et il répond à toutes les questions
intéressant parce que c'est des
questions tu amènes n'ya pas des
contrôles à table un ballet j'imagine un
mondial question importante parce que
parce que il ya d'abord l'émotion
la première fut d'abord la première
chose que j'ai dit c'est d'abord ma
pensée pour toutes ces femmes la
deuxième c'est l'émotion
on en a parlé la troisième c'est le fond
de ce dossier du dossier c'est le droit
le droit
il ya zéro plainte il ya zéro ouverture
d'information judiciaire
vous imaginez avec la force de frappe
puissante du documentaire qui est passé
que j'ai vu qui a été bien relié et dont
je me suis abstenu au départ de parler
je vous explique pourquoi d'ailleurs je
me suis abstenu de parler au départ
c'est parce qu'il faut laisser parler
les femmes
il faut laisser parler ses importants
dans l'époque d'écouté donc je ne
voulais pas venir m'exprimer sur votre
plateau d'abord à partir du moment où
tout a été dit le procureur de la
république
le parquet il peut peut-être
certainement peut-être changer d'avis
pour l'instant elle n'a pas été le cas
n'a pas ouvert d'information judiciaire
une personne avait à l'époque déposé
plainte
c'était la sphère nike ça s'est passé ça
s'est terminé juste avec un simple
rappel à la loi ce qui veut dire que
d'une agression sexuelle ou un viol ou
peu importe que sage qu'elle n'apporte
délit n'a pas été caractérisée vous avez
son ancien stagiaire qui avait déposé
plainte après une année dans quête il
avait déposé plainte en septembre 2019
je la semence ensuite en octobre 2020
c'est à dire que c'est une vraie enquête
il a été même auditionné au commissariat
de boulogne billancourt j'étais avec lui
razer classement sans suite mon client a
déposé plainte pour diffamation publique
il y aura une audience le 14 juin 2022
il devra s'en expliquer et sur le
fondement de cette sur ce classement
sans suite
il ya eu un dépôt de plainte en
dénonciation calomnieuse
donc pour résumer zéro plainte
c'est à ces héros arthur d'information
judiciaire vous avez une plainte qui
s'est terminée en classant sans suite ou
mon client derrière a déposé une plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse et ensuite
une plainte en diffamation publique et
une autre plainte qui s'est terminée
avec un simple rappel à la loi
alors je veux bien et je respecte il
manque encore une fois je les respecte
j'écoute tout ce qui se dit justement
mais le tribunal public ne s'est pas
twitter alors justement m vous comprenez
que le jeu fifa ait décidé de retirer la
voix de pierre ménès de moi je vous dis
je condamne absolument mais la façon la
plus ferme ce café lettré ingrate se
fait pas avec mon confrère maître
nicolas robaux nous avons mises en
demeure fifa d'accord parce qu'on règle
pas moi j'ai jamais vu ça mais peut-être
que c'est peut-être la pax et on y
arrive on ne résilie pas un contrat
ouais sur twitter on ne résilie pas en
fait on fait pas de reproche sur twitter
sur des faits qui sont potentiellement
reprochés moi c'est pas ça le droit ici
vous avez attaqué on a en a mise en
demeure
d'accord il faut on leur demande des
comptes et je peux vous garantir que
s'ils ne répondent pas ça sera une
assignation bien sûr bien sûr au
littoral dean alors je vous écoute
attentivement et j'entends vos éléments
de langage et moi je suis comme où t'as
l'air je partage le fait que quand un
homme après tout a fauté ou une femme
d'ailleurs il a droit
une sorte de parcours de résilience de
seconde chance absolument pourquoi pas
mais c'est pas les médias qui ont accusé
pierre ménès en fait et aujourd'hui il
ya une enquête qui est diligentée par sa
chaîne par canal dire qu'il a peut-être
voulu partir du canal football club
mais la chaîne ne voulais pas qu'ils
restent au canal football club alors
vous dit une vérité une contre-vérité
alors dites moi absolument d'abord sairi
ville a entrepris les compétences a été
fait en commun accord c'est à dire que
au regard du de la force de frappe
du déchaînement qui eût mérité dans un
certain sens on il l'a même d'ailleurs
bon client l'a d'ailleurs dit shah manas
s'est mis en retrait en commun accord
avec la direction de canal + frais vous
pensez que s'il avait voulu rester il
aurait maintenu
moi je suis pas la place de la direction
de canal+ c'est vrai que c'est pierre
qui a voulu se retirer
il est là de de l'antenne benguerrah
inquiète c'est un garçon qui est très
sensible mais il ya un mot que vous avez
des collègues ne le soutiennent pas mais
l'atout ne soutient pas bien ça y est le
souteneur parler leurs noms des autres
madame oui c'est vrai vide et se parlent
en tout cas mais peu importe ne me
sépare les gens vous savez on parle d'un
sujet qui est taboue
absolument et je vais vous dire une
chose elle fait ce titre 99 % des
dossiers que je soutiens à moi dans les
tribunaux ce sont des femmes ou des
enfants victimes
c'est quasiment l'un des seuls premiers
dossiers dans lesquels je sus pris dans
un dossier sur lequel je pense
profondément que pierre ménès n'est pas
un délinquant sexuel
bien sûr et je ne veux pas pour mais
tous sur un même plan parce qu'à notre
époque la facilité voudrait qu'on met
tout sur le même niveau qu'hier mais là
ce n'est pas un délinquant sexuel
c'est un homme qui a une profonde
sensibilité il a eu l'humilité de dire
que ces gestes n'étaient pas appropriés
c'est je pense que rien que pour ça on
peut tendre la main il ya un mot que
vous avez utilisé sa résilience mois
j'utiliserai le terme rédemption juste
je pense que tu as était pas que c'est
important la fonction par h m et qu'elle
ait le dernier mot vous auriez envie de
dire ce soir concernant pierre ménès où
on est on de la faire alors alors la
faire placer n'y a pas d'affaires
d'accor dont il ya eu donc c'est dit on
a pris acte du documentaire je rends
hommage à toutes ces à toutes ces
personnes qui ont ce qui se sont
exprimés je regrette même d'ailleurs
qu'il ce documentaire parce que ça veut
dire qu'un dysfonctionnement
ce documentaire ne devrait même pas
exister parce que si les signes s'il
existe c'est qu'il ya un
dysfonctionnement profond dans notre
société et et moi je rends hommage et
j'espère que de nombreuses femmes ne
seront pas simples en plus à l'antenne
mais son dirigeant de cac 40
ils seront manager et d'autres déjà
beaucoup l'égalité homme-femme et c'est
bon les gars comme fabrice ehret et
chacun de vous tous c'est un objectif
pour notre société
et si quelqu'un fait un acte
approprié je demande juste une chose
qu'on ne regarde pas le passé avec les
lunettes du présent c'est tout ce que je
demande on peut juger castaldi ce même
si jaloux ces jeunes sont magnifiques
alors voilà alors franchement on voulait
avoir des nouvelles opéré sans voir ce
qu'on pense les téléspectateurs de de
cette affaire de la question oui à 62 %
regarder les médias ont-ils fait qu'on
allait perdre et est soumis à 70 son nom
à 38% mais